there are more Transformers out there
than meets the eye but which one packs
the biggest punch here are the top picks
for the most powerful Transformers out
there
RC has popped up in many incarnations
over the decades since her initial
appearance in 1986's the Transformers
the movie making her one of the more
difficult characters to track without
flying fully off the rails noting how
complicated its chronology can be Hasbro
launched an attempt at bringing various
takes on Transformers together under a
shared continuity in 2010. this soft
reboot saw what is perhaps the most
definitive take on RC in Transformers
Prime where fans saw her stepping into
more of a main character role for the
first two seasons as that take on RC
Blended a few details from the past and
reimagined her in other ways it seemed
likely that will be the basis of her
character in Rise of the beasts RC is
considered one of the least physically
intimidating Transformers but her
intense willpower makes her one of
Optimus Prime's most trusted allies in
the Prime series RC can transform into a
blue motorcycle projecting a hologram
named Sadie as the driver to be less
easily identifiable by humans and
Decepticons she can turn her hands into
blades or blasters like many of her
fellow Autobots but her greatest
strength might be the ability to achieve
great things under pressure having lost
friends in battle before she's committed
to making sure it never happens again
and that resolve is what makes her such
a formidable foe another character
hailing from the first generation of
Autobots the original form of Mirage was
a bit different than the one in
Transformers rise of the beasts although
he's undergone several iterations at
this point he remains one of the most
complicated Autobots
coming from wealth he joined the group
in the fight against the Decepticons but
has long-held sympathies across the
board despite knowing that the
Decepticons are wrong and Must Be
Stopped he likewise disagrees with the
methods of the Autobots it makes him a
bit of a wild card with an arrogant but
Charming demeanor to top it all off he
remains one of the most interesting
characters in Transformers history
along with that unique personality
Mirage has a highly individualized skill
set for his name's sake he can cast
projections of himself to confuse
enemies he also has the ability to turn
invisible and even emulate other
Autobots Mirage previously appeared in
the form of a Ferrari 458 but for Rise
of the beasts he's a Porsche though this
design Harkens back to Prior
incarnations it is worth noting that
fellow Autobot Jazz was the one designed
after a Porsche whether this means the
film franchise will be merging these two
fan favorites or has more to do with
behind the scenes technicalities is
unclear regardless mirage's subterfuge
makes him a powerful asset to the
Autobots
eagle-eyed viewers might have noticed a
lightning fast glimpse of night bird in
the Transformers rise of the beasts
trailer appearing in only one episode of
the original cartoon this is the kind of
deep cut they live to spot enter the
night bird introduced viewers to Dr
Fujiyama who created nightbird for the
dubious purpose of proving how great
technology is and how helpful it can be
to humanity the cartoon showed
surprising foresight by explaining that
this helpful Tech was immediately
hijacked by Decepticons and used for
evil though the Autobots ultimately
defeat her she remains in stasis
returning for Universe the Wreckers and
other brief appearances down the line
particularly in the IDW Comics while
some might assume that there will be
changes in night Bird's origin with a
new take on the character it'll be hard
to improve much on the perfect concept
of a ninja robot bent on destruction not
a Decepticon or an Autobot but simply a
robot programmed with the skills of a
ninja most of night Bird's abilities lie
in her hand-to-hand combat skills
besides the throwing stars she also
wields a powerful Bean katana
this grizzled weapons expert of the
Autobots is one of the franchise's
longest running characters dating back
to that opening three-parter more than
meets the eye one of Optimus Prime's
oldest friends his tenacity has seen him
survive countless conflicts more to the
point and Gruff than the others it would
be easy to dismiss him as a curmudgeon
if he wasn't a true softy at heart he's
a fan favorite who has shown up in just
about every Transformer's adaptation to
date adding a serious dose of
down-to-earth mentality to the crew
though his specific continuity has
shifted over the decades he remains one
of the tried and true believers in
Optimus Prime's fight against the
Decepticons let's blast their tail
Runners out of there though Ironhide
might not be the most powerful in a
direct attack he is the go-to of the
Autobots when it comes to protection
sporting trithilium steel skin that
makes him essentially invulnerable he
often serves as The Bodyguard of Optimus
Prime stepping in to deflect attacks
while the others leap into action
he is equipped for battle with a special
gun which can blast targets with any
kind of liquid favoring liquid nitrogen
still there is little denying that his
greatest strength is an inability to
call it quits regardless of what
challenges arise
bumblebee not raiding higher on this
list might seem like a snub but it's not
the character has survived a franchise
that a lot of characters haven't so this
entry is made with the utmost respect to
be what he lacks in the overwhelming
strength of characters like Optimus
Prime he makes up four in sheer
determination which is shown him capable
of overpowering much stronger foes
appearing early on with the first
generation of Transformers characters he
has long been considered the heart of
the Autobots making him indispensable
for the group's morale in ways that
would be difficult to quantify there's
no denying that his ability to stay
optimistic even in the most upsetting of
situations is practically a superpower
in and of itself
[Music]
while he first appeared in the form of
an adorable yellow Volkswagen Bug he's
been redesigned to incorporate more of a
muscle car look now appearing as a
yellow Camaro with b-like racing stripes
he has many of the same basic weapons as
the other Transformers including body
separation abilities and energy Shield
plasma rifles and Rockets yet
Bumblebee's true power comes from within
while his upbeat attitude is infectious
among the occasionally dower Autobots
bumblebee is just as determined as the
rest of them on the battlefield they
have regularly relied on his scouting
abilities as well as his Superior
Marksmanship
all of the major Decepticons are
powerful including Heavy Hitters like
lockdown and sound wave at the top of
Megatron's list of cronies is Shockwave
one of the main antagonists of 2011's
Dark of the Moon
rumored to be capable of defeating even
Megatron in combat this deadly scientist
creates a cult of personality he gains
followers like the last night bill in
Nitro Zeus who commits acts of Terror in
his name even after his demise
ultimately his body was used by KSI to
create the less intimidating but still
scary two-head who died via a hand
grenade that's probably the last we'll
see Shockwave but at this point his
resilience is a superpower in and of
itself
though his adherence to logic is a
built-in character flaw that leads to
his undoing his misdeeds have had
surprising longevity in the franchise
shockwave's ability to influence others
is put into play at various times
including when he uses his power to
create subservient clones of himself to
fight for him during battles he can
transform into a tank redirect blasts by
opening portals and fight Autobots to a
standstill through hand-to-hand combats
yet the threat he poses is primarily in
his ability to develop great weapons for
the Decepticons heading up nefarious
schemes like project Predacon creating
cyber matter and the restoration of the
Omega lock
Grimlock is a big scary dude with a big
scary sword who can also turn into a big
scary T-Rex he's a pretty solid fighter
as well he leads the Dinobots a
relatively small team that backs a
pretty nasty punch the Dinobots value
strength and intensity so it takes an
extremely powerful leader to claim
dominance over the rest of the group
Grimlock has shown off his fighting
prowess on several occasions and has
held his own against and even defeated
some of the veritable who's who list of
Transformers
however he loses more often than not
when he Tangles with any of the Big
Timers and his prickly instinctive
nature makes it so he often gets in over
his head when battling against
physically Superior foes
if it just came down to purely physical
and mental ability Megatron might be
able to jump a few spots on this list as
the leader of the Decepticons Megatron
has proven time and time again that he
can go toe-to-toe against any
Transformer out there he's powerful and
strategic and he truly believes in what
he's fighting for that said Megatron
often fails when he should succeed
because his arrogance and disdain for
others comes back to haunt him Megatron
believes that Transformers are the
superior life forms in the universe and
any other creature that he deems
inferior is barely worth recognizing
this arrogance has led to countless
plans failing due to Megatron
overlooking a small detail if he was
able to see the big picture or recognize
the threat that others posed to his
plans it's possible the Decepticons
would have achieved their goals of
universal domination long ago depending
on which timeline and version of
Transformers you're looking at
galvatron's power level can fluctuate
wildly sometimes he's little more than a
modified version of Megatron other times
he has gained near omnipotence through a
combination of outside forces cunning
and force of will when Megatron was
destroyed he made a deal with Unicron to
be reborn as Galvatron though Galvatron
possesses all of Megatron's Memories the
rebirth changed the Decepticon forever
after his defeat by the Autobots
Galvatron was driven insane his new
Quest as leader of the Decepticons was
to do whatever it took to gain more
power for himself
galvatron's quest for Domination has led
him to some extremely powerful mythical
artifacts that have made him almost
Invincible even when battling the most
dangerous beings in the universe when he
hits His Highest levels of strength even
entire forces of the most powerful
Transformers can do little to stop him
like Megatron's arrogance galvatron's
lust for power is his biggest downfall
he will throw his companions aside and
break ancient taboos to achieve his
goals meaning almost everyone is Allied
against him
strong
Optimus Prime doesn't Edge out Megatron
and Grimlock on Battle prowess alone
he's proven himself an extremely capable
fighter time and time again and his
status as the leader of the Autobots
isn't a fluke that said Optimus Prime's
true power comes from those intangible
characteristics that also make him a
good leader he's courageous thoughtful
strategic and never underestimates his
enemies
Autobots transform and roll out these
traits help Optimus Prime stand up to
much more powerful forces his drive and
compassion helped him stay in fights
much longer than he should be able to
and he often demoralizes his foes simply
because his will never breaks Optimus
Prime is legendary in the Transformers
Universe for turning the tide of many
conflicts on his sheer will and courage
he has sacrificed himself on countless
occasions and taken down many a more
powerful foe by outmaneuvering them and
relying on the help of his friends and
allies Optimus Prime can never be
counted out of any fight
Defensor is the combiner version of the
five protectobots hotspot first aid
blades StreetWise and groove he isn't
particularly strong on offense but he
does flex his power levels in other ways
for one Defensor is one of the most
intelligent and strategic Minds on any
Battlefield the protectibots are all
emergency responders so they need to be
able to analyze situations quickly and
effectively to save lives he's no slouch
on the battlefield certainly but
Defensor has one other trick up his
robotic sleeve a massive incredibly
strong force field that can be projected
up to 50 feet away from his body
defensor's force field takes a massive
amount of energy to maintain but it's an
extremely powerful ability the Autobots
usually get in trouble when they're
stretched too thin trying to protect
everyone Defensor earns a spot on the
list because he bypasses that weakness
entirely whenever he's on the
battlefield
Predaking is what is known as a combiner
which is a Transformer made up of other
Transformers as such his power level is
significant Predaking is a combination
of the five other Predacons dive bomb
headstrong Rampage razor claw and
tantrum he is massive extremely powerful
and one of the most dangerous hunters in
the Galaxy Predaking also has some other
abilities that make him extraordinarily
strong but one stands out that makes him
unique among other combiners one of the
drawbacks when a Transformer shifts into
its combiner form is that all of them
have to work together the different
Transformers are still independent
beings and if they disagree about which
action to take there isn't much they can
do the five Transformers who become
Predaking molt together into one
Consciousness preventing that drawback
it makes for an extremely dangerous foe
capable of isolating and destroying his
enemies predaking's main weakness is his
Lust For The Hunt he has been lured into
more than a few traps when he thinks
he's already won
Bruticus is the mirror of Defensor he's
made up of the five Combaticons
Onslaught Vortex brawl blast off and
swindle each of these decepticons
transform into military vehicles and
when they join together become the
extremely powerful Bruticus Bruticus
possesses all sorts of advanced weaponry
and is nearly impervious to attacks
despite being a combiner each of the
five Transformers that makes up this
monstrosity is driven by similar
instincts thus it isn't very hard for
them to find a common purpose and work
together in their Bruticus form
bruticus's Central weakness is his
Intelligence being driven solely by
aggression makes him extremely
suggestible and dumb he's easy to trick
and will follow any orders that allow
him to get into battle his brute
strength is unquestionable making him a
terrible threat he just needs someone
else to pull the strings for him
not this way you treater as old I can't
control it if Trypticon carry a bit more
he'd be practically Unstoppable he's
what's known as a Titan in one form he's
a massive dinosaur capable of defeating
nearly any Transformer in hand-to-hand
combats even worse his alternate form is
a city-sized artillery platform capable
of launching massive amounts of
Firepower in an incredibly short amount
of time very few can stand up to
trypticon's insane size and weaponry and
entire teams of Autobots will generally
use trickery and subversion to stand up
to him they know that a head-on assault
would be suicide despite being the
Ultimate Weapon trypticon's heart is not
often in the battle Trypticon hates the
Autobots but he also hates that he's
used as a tool by the Decepticons he has
accepted his role as a deadly weapon but
he frequently becomes jaded or
dispirited with the constant fighting
he's involved in this disinterest is one
of the few things that gives the
Autobots a chance against such a
dangerous foe Metroplex is an Autobot
Titan like his Decepticon counterpart
Trypticon his alternate form is a
massive City and his Autobot form is a
towering intimidating figure that
dwarves almost any other Transformer in
existence
both of us he has three regular-sized
Autobots Scamper Six Gun and Slammer
just to help him keep track of
everything happening around him
Metroplex is just too big to monitor it
all himself Metroplex is a highly
skilled Marksman and hand-to-hand
fighter capable of scrapping with nearly
any phone he's loyal intelligent and
courageous and the Autobots frequently
rely on his judgment metroplex's
greatest trait however is his humility
despite his massive size fighting
prowess and intelligence he never feels
it is enough he constantly wants to do
better and improve and he's always
looking for ways to overcome obstacles
and help make the world a better place
even when the odds are against him
Metroplex is constantly searching for
ways to even things out and give the
good guys the edge in battle
Omega Supreme is millions of years old
he once served as the guardian of
cybertron's biggest city currently he's
an Intergalactic transport for the rest
of the Autobots his alternate form is
three different things a huge tank and
two military bases
Omega Supreme is seemingly the largest
Autobot in existence and he is
overpowered beyond belief his armor
makes him invulnerable to all but the
most powerful attacks and he has enough
Firepower in both of his forms to defeat
entire teams in a one-on-one fight he
would crush nearly any opposition on top
of all this Omega Supreme has an
incredible drive to protect and serve he
despises the destructive attitude of the
Decepticons and works tirelessly with
Optimus Prime and the other Autobots to
safeguard those who are in danger
generally viewed as the final line of
defense he's powerful enough to handle
most threats on his own
you could put any of the primes here a
group of the 13 original Transformers
created to become masters of different
aspects of the universe each of these
beings commands almost Godlike Powers
but Vector Prime Takes the Cake for a
few different reasons Vector Prime once
held the Matrix of leadership but he
left Cybertron to become the guardian of
time and space he can warp both of these
things with his powers and he can travel
through and observe the Multiverse at
will this allows him to influence events
across space time and Alternate
Dimensions like the rest of the primes
Vector Prime is several billion years
old and his existence outside of regular
space and time has left him with a bit
of a disconnect from the universe that
said his heart is in the right place and
there is little that other Transformers
can do to stop him once he decides on a
plan of action
appearing in 2017's Transformers the
last night as one of the film's main
antagonists quintessa is a character
with the potential to be the most
powerful of all the Transformers
Prime of life while there are plenty of
claims she makes that may or may not be
true she certainly was one of the most
entertaining aspects of a movie that is
regularly derided by fans of the
franchise while the Autobots believe her
to be deceased after Bumblebee's attack
the film's final sequences indicated
that she is alive and well passing her
time in human disguise presumably
cooking up new nefarious schemes
quintessa's skill set is absolutely wild
even in a franchise full of immensely
powerful characters but it's easy to
feel that her most valuable asset is the
ability to play the long game while the
others get tangled up in battles
quintessa tends to be looking to the
next conflict to gauge how the events
will benefit her this is Amplified by
abilities like holographic camouflage
hypnosis and telekinesis alongside her
physical attacks like energy projection
and redirection however her most
chilling Talent is likely the power to
transfigure the cybertronians through
her power of creation quite literally
reverting Galvatron to Megatron form to
suit her needs in the last night
most fans of Transformers will remember
unicron's appearance in the 80s animated
film this Godlike Transformer is the
most terrifying being in the universe
his entire reason to exist is to destroy
everything until he is the sole
remaining life form he consumes entire
world breaking down everything they have
and using it to boost his capabilities
Unicron can travel across the Multiverse
at will and his presence is seen as a
plague on reality itself his powers are
unlimited and he can infiltrate and
infest different aspects of the universe
in his never-ending quest to Snuff out
life he also seduces other beings under
his thrall granting them new powers in
exchange for their sworn fealty because
of the power he can bestow many accept
his offers despite knowing their
destruction always lies at the end of
the deal
brother to Unicron and the only being in
the universe who can stand up to him
Primus is the stand-in for God in the
Transformers Universe Primus created the
Transformers and a small part of him
exists within all his Creations as the
Transformers create and maintain most
other aspects of the universe Primus has
his hands in nearly everything he exists
across time space and separate realities
his physical manifestation exists as the
Transformers home planet of Cybertron he
has access to nearly all the information
in existence through his Mainframe
computer Vector Sigma this wealth of
knowledge available to Primus is what
helps him Edge out Unicron as the most
powerful Transformer in existence his
ability to out think and strategize
circles around his sibling keeps the
universe intact his ability to exist
across space and time gives him the edge
whenever he's needed
foreign